[Musique]
nous allons aujourd'hui
neyret
[Musique]
pour
non
[Musique]
m
voilà
[Musique]
pour
des shows date lui de revenir au slip
d'autres jusqu'à 1800 belle au slip
alors non c'est pas que symbolique la
première chose qu'on demande c'est
évidemment la mise à l'abri de ces
personnes qui auraient déjà dû l'être
avec l'évacuation du camp de saint denis
et puis la deuxième chose qu'on demande
c'est de cesser ce cycle infernal des
campements qui se forme qui sont
évacuées souvent dans la violence qui se
reforment voilà on veut en terminer avec
ce cycle infernal et qui est un vrai
dispositif pour l'accueil de ces
personnes et nous sommes assis à figer
aujourd'hui de voir que finalement les
recommandations qui ont été faites par
msf n'ont pas franchement été suivie
puisque lors du démantèlement de saint
denis
c'est encore pour envoyer des gens en
gymnase il ya un manque d'hébergement
qui aurait dû être anticipé depuis la
première vague et le résultat voilà ce
sont toutes ces personnes qui sont
toujours à la rue avec des arrivées tous
les jours